just 10 days ago the ukrainian army and
russian forces bought pitch battles in
the streets of makarev
now an army of volunteers is fighting a
different one to clean up the streets
their weapons
old-fashioned rooms and physical
strength
[Applause]
these people are members of a
bodybuilding club in kiev who've come to
help alongside their friends
they sweep into this supermarket
we are trying to clean up the mess that
the russians left behind
we are trying to bring normality to our
country
but it's dangerous work mines and booby
traps are everywhere they work with the
military to stay as safe as they can
we're asking for the military guys and
from national guard i found two bombs
but it was exploded
on the garden
a little bit
because me
the task ahead is daunting even with
volunteers in the civil administration
it'll take years to get this town back
to anything resembling what it was
facilities like the local library and
community center will be the last to be
rebuilt
after all without homes for people to
live in
there can be no community
that v was painted on that gate by the
russians they'd taken over this entire
area you can just see over there the
empty ammunition cases they used as
defensive positions but the ukrainians
have now been through this area
they've searched house to house see that
yellow dot over there that yellow dot
symbolizes the fact that this house has
been cleared of mines and any kind of
booby traps and the residents are now
back here and what they're doing is
they're rebuilding slowly but surely
soldiers are still clearing houses here
they look in this cellar methodically
making sure there's nothing that might
explode
the woman who lives here watches
nervously
satisfied it's clear the soldiers leave
it's this type of operation that will
allow those who still have some hope to
return
this ukrainian tank has become a
makeshift memorial to those who died
defending this place the residents have
left flowers
flowers that have wilted and died
but as the long process to clean up
begins when they return perhaps fresh
flowers will as well
imran khan al jazeera makarov